[Music]
so I'm in Toronto right now this is
actually my first time here I've never
really been to Canada of the Montreal
once for like two days but it was so
cold I stayed inside
oh the Niagara Falls one but I don't
really think that count so now we're in
Kensington Square market George and I
get some lunch
you can you waffles what
she'll be enlarged when you just walk by
maybe
[Music]
looking for food we found a lot of
tattoos a lot of dispensaries not quite
we serve things we need
[Music]
okay so it feels really good here I'm
quite surprised a fuss a clause in the
salad
now I had enough you I just called me
Eaton Centre Mall and there's an Apple
store there so we're going to do that
we're also going to go to Tim Hortons
and get a doughnut and a coffee
let's take our uber uber is arriving is
that our uber all right for Justin yes
I've got good how are you
[Music]
[Applause]
all right how to film I can ride
Josh hey here we go read Obamacare yeah
oh my gosh it's raining raining reading
Google
oh boy oh my I see a lego store or no
lego t-shirt domain assume that it was
like five seconds I was invited oh wow
Glen crafter my favorite place sighs
well floods promise you my violin
contacts therapy of today and every time
they ship them to my parents house so
right now I'm on like my last pair of
contacts I have one more pair for
tomorrow until I go back to my parents
house to get my contacts Oh
natural wellness this looks like an
older designed Apple store it kinda
reminds me of the one back in South
Hills Village from my hometown if I feel
like we're at home
like again this is the 101
my first Apple school bag and shopping
experience in Canada we're at the ball
feel real American I actually forgot
that we were in rural Canada and we were
in the Oberer and the guy was like so
sorry about Trump and I was like oh but
you're right we can't I forgot the
person I met the Kamal sir she's
crossing things off the list
left and right actually we're just going
down the list it's not really like right
I guess if you're profitably off or
fully processed left to right if you
guys are robbing something off would you
start from the left would you cross it
off from the right now I'm curious we're
going to go it's important now so let's
do that
Keter well the doughnut and it's too
leaning how is this possible Wow the
craning on my clothes
camera not waterproof
[Music]
that's important don't not and my
Timmy's coffee it's really hot the today
we're still in Toronto and I'm heading
to a YouTube event now we're doing
rehearsals and then the actual event is
happening it's called YouTube pulse it's
sort of like the brand cast / creator
summit thing that we went to in New York
this past month but it's here in Canada
it's a little bit smaller than the one
in New York had a lot of fun roaming
around yesterday in Toronto I mean it's
kind of crazy but this is like my first
time here oh my god
[Music]
um I just dropped my camera this is my
microphone alright so let's see if this
actually works so you guys witness which
is happened like my camera just fell out
of my head on the floor dragged it off
of you and yeah that's forgot hangry I
don't like I just fell and I just looked
at and just started yelling but I think
it's gonna be okay and I think it fell
on microphone so let's eat the
microphone works isn't even working I
don't know
there's piece of it you okay okay
testing testing the audio are you still
working are you yeah I'm also huge dance
video game Mario Kart Elsa makes cooking
videos a vintage cooking
please welcome I just seen you seeking
an unboxing
this experience isn't a one-way
broadcast it's a two-way conversation
and one of the features that makes
YouTube special is the way in the box
and are able to come together
she's communities around her favorite
content Pennsylvania I went from LA to
Toronto for a few days and now I'm good
sister and that's hard to visit my
family but I also in Pittsburgh because
there's a tool concert now a lot of you
guys might not know this or you might
know this that I'm a huge tool fan and I
have been for a really long time on
Monday I get to go see them and I'm
doing like the VIP experience so they
have like that's really cool like meet
and greet and all of the stuff but you
have to check in really early and by
early I mean the doors for the show it's
6:30 so we have to get there and check
in by 12:30 which is super early I'm in
Brie's house bring out here my parents
are doing some work around the place and
I'm so excited about this this is a pie
and I've been looking at this pie from
Brie's old house to her new house and
this time has enticed me so many time
here's the sad reality the five not real
it's a candle I hate this thing I hate
it so much the cake is a lie hi beau
how are you are you looking for
something to eat
this is a crazy place you probably
already saw the house tour on Jenna's
channel which I thought was really funny
it was like HDTV style I'm also just
kind of looking for a place to take a
nap one of the difficult things about
being home is the Wi-Fi in super-slow my
parents house so I had to stay up until
1:30 trying to finish a video and
one exported I had to upload it
overnight look at this bathroom
I feel like this bathroom is so perfect
for singing in the showers and stuff and
I absolutely love the Harry Styles out
like I love it so much it's so
incredible every song is so unique and
just different I might not be different
in sort of the singer-songwriter Sal
you're on rope man for Harry Styles I
just I love it so much so good I guess
I'll lay with you because they don't
have a couch yet so to get both tension
yeah if they cry oh well let's get
ourselves a drink
[Music]
I'm so excited today long insist Berg
and I'm in preferred number one to visit
my family and number two because there
is a tool concert and I am I'm
speechless I've been a tool fan since I
was in high school which was probably
around a 19 ahhhhh was probably 1999 if
you're told and you know that they don't
tour very often and when they do you got
to go you've got to go
heading down now to check in and meet my
friend Desiree you guys know des and if
you don't know des it must mean you're
newer fan Denton I used to go to so many
shows when we were in college we
actually live together we did pretty
much everything together Sol's like des
I'm home we gotta go see tool and the
one response that she had was I remember
when we lived together you would be
blaring your heavy metal music and I
would be trying to sleep very very
accurate
[Music]
we made it yeah this is going to be so
great we haven't been to a show together
in a while what's the big one - yeah I
told them earlier that you said that I
used to play my heavy metal music really
loud at night no see then kept me up all
night
okay we're off to see - lets go let's go
let's go
vlogging on my phone cuz they're going
to take it and we're not a lot of
cameras gothic feel like I'm going to
some sort of prison
[Music]
he'll only wait friends I never ended my
vlog now I never ended the vlog but this
vlog seems like it was basically
never-ending I mean so many things
happened in this video it's been over
the course of several weeks there are a
few loose ends that I needed to tie up
some logging on my iPhone I packed up
everything I'm about to head downtown
for e3 it's coming up super super soon
some things that I needed to address I
needed to finish up my story of talking
about to land what they mean to me
the first let's go through our goodie
bags that we got it was so crazy not
being able to have my phone or do
anything I mean I completely had no
contact wait that's the drumstick that
hurt okay cold
20:17 toll keychains we've got a
wristband oh it's like a little USB
charge my leg hurts from drumming on it
I'm an idiot guitar picks I used to know
so many of the tool intros to their
songs of course they were never probably
correct and I'm probably just playing in
the wrong key and not at the correct
rhythm it was this great bag so in high
school I I don't know I mean I'd like to
say I was a little eccentric I'm not
sure I didn't really do all the things
that most other people were doing I did
a lot of the opposite actually if
somebody liked something I was like I
don't like that the Taliban tool around
I definitely listened to different types
of musics and I feel like I listen to
now I mean now I pretty much listen to
like top 50 I just go on Spotify alright
top 100 songs cool I'm gonna listen to
that I used to listen to a lot of I
guess heavy metal music definitely a lot
heavier than I listen to now
but tool was one of the bands that just
I gravitated to so much and for so many
different reasons their music their
music videos them in general they're
always so super secretive like you don't
know anything really about them you
never know what's going on their
shoulder always so strange and weird and
just so different than anything else
that I feel like anybody else is doing
well for me I was like that's pretty
cool tool is like me they don't do
things the traditional way they're not a
radio band but yet they can still sell
out
arenas to this day which is so freakin
awesome anyway it was just so much fun I
could go on and talking about this
pretty much forever because high school
Justine was basically living out
something that she never really would
have thought was possible I know for a
lot of you guys you guys are probably
young or maybe you're my age or you're
older but if you are young if you are in
high school or middle school no matter
what is going on in your life right now
you're going to look back on that time
and just be like wow because I'm looking
back like 20 years ago where I was and
what I was doing and I still sort of
have those same interests but how this
band has impacted me how Steve Jobs has
impacted me how my parents have impacted
everything that I'm doing so those are
sort of like my three main inspirations
my parents Steve Jobs pool we had this
one high school art project where I was
creating a stop-motion video I was
trying to recreate the sober music video
I let me tell you what
[Music]
my final project looked like trash I was
going through frame by frame trying to
like recreate this entire insane imagery
and I did a pretty terrible job but I
feel like the combination of loving
Apple and loving the creativity and the
eccentric nature of tool are some of the
two things that for me in high school
really powered my motivation to get into
doing things that are creative to making
videos and not worrying about the
traditional route and the way that
people are normally supposed to do
things so what I'm saying
if people might tell you one thing and
you might believe another so it's not
always a bad thing to sort of go your
own route but don't always disregard
things that people tell you because a
lot of times people have already lived
through the things that you're dealing
with they'll struggle that you might be
going through now I might have already
had those your parents are probably
already gone through the same thing
whoever is giving you that advice it
could be coming from a place of saying
hey I don't want you to make the same
mistake that I did but yet here's the
kicker we're still going to do it anyway
because most of the time and
unfortunately the only way that you
learn your lesson is by making the
mistake yourself this video has gone I
don't even know which direction I'm
going to leave you guys because I have
to go finish packing and I just realized
my other camera is right here and I
could have been using an actual camera I
packed up my other vlogging camera cuz
I'm ready to go and I'm heading out now
and I could have used a real one
whatever at this point in this video if
anybody has made it this far
go comment hallelujah in the comment
they're just going to give you guys a
little PSA here you probably shouldn't
fly a drone in the fog I knew it was a
bad idea but I did it anyway which is
usually even said that did not even say
in the beginning of this is a bad idea
oh my god is taking off oh my god wait
oh no wait am i doing that I think you
are nope I'm not I'm definitely not
doing that landing not listening to me
at all no I can't do it again so not
only is it like raining it's super misty
so it started interfering with my drone
and it started landing by itself and I
had to run into the bush and land uses a
bush and just grow I did yeah yeah there
was like a motherly instinct that kicked
in and I dove into those bushes to save
my baby that's the fastest I've ever
seen her move hi Ralph hello I'm
vlogging on my iPhone today cuz it's
pretty cool just easier where are we
right now we're on set look around
mythical morning good morning I'm so
excited
me too I feel like we're on set of like
this iconic I'm you'd is iconic I know I
almost want to leave something that's
like Oh click in the background okay a
little Easter Egg do you want to think
about it links can be like no don't do
it so I'm going to come in knowing
something is not a place I should have
brought something I didn't bring
anything I bet I can find something okay
there's a really great chance that this
vlog could possibly be from the past
month I film a lot of stuff and then I
never edited and right now I am
currently recovering from the week of
III if you're new to my channel that's
probably all that you've seen this week
is me talking about video games and
going to Easter day but today I slept
all day I had a TV installation and let
me tell you what the TV that I got is by
far the most incredible thing that I've
ever seen there'll be a separate video
about that but today this is just a blog
it's just a vlog and we are celebrating
my sweet baby boy's birthday I street
boy do you know that your two today
three two years old
[Music]
doggy here hello birthday boy okay Manny
stuff for you easy - lobster birthday
boy hey birthday boy you you hate it
what if it goes like this is that that
hurt yeah that's just not very
flattering it
happy birthday nudity how much do you
hate what you're wearing right now do
you hate it could you look handsome
what's wrong you trying to hide it are
you trying to hide the bone hide it so
no one can get it where do you think
you're going
sassy spot
[Music]